[Música]
eu tô aqui pra dizer pra vocês
empoderamento feminino precisa passar
pela [ __ ] é estranho ainda né
uma mulher usar um termo sexual se
referir ao seu órgão sexual
se fosse um homem tudo bem eu acho ele
fala pau [ __ ] mas uma mulher falando
[ __ ] é meio revolucionário ainda é
estranho que seja não pra mim porque eu
cresci em uma família patriarcal onde a
mulher podia absolutamente tudo o poder
feminino não era passível de
questionamento na minha família meu pai
morreu quando tinha quatro anos deixou
minha mãe comigo criança e comecei mais
adolescentes para criar maior encrenca
né mas que ela nunca reclamou
nunca vi uma vez ela reclamar de ter que
sustentar e criar quatro mulheres e um
evento numa bolha matriarcal era só
mulher ao redor de sua mulher poderosa
tanto por isso até o demorei para
entender o feminismo não entendia o que
elas queriam tanto porque não é ao redor
eu só vi a mulher poderosa e mulheres
sendo respeitada
então na minha casa éramos eu e minha
mãe minhas irmãs minha volta e morava
com a gente a gente tinha uma motorista
mulher também as funcionárias todas da
empresa da minha mãe para mulheres teve
uma vez um homem que trabalhou lá e foi
isolado numa salinha eu nem sei o que
aconteceu com ele sumiu e era um velho
mágico parecia assim eu acho meio à ilha
sabe que a mulher maravilha foi criada
só tinha mulheres e de certa forma a
minha mãe que me criar para que eu fosse
uma mulher maravilha que na concepção
dela era ser uma mulher livre
então tudo podia quer ficar de pé
descalço brincar com os meninos pode
quer comer miojo meia noite enquanto
estados como também
todas as crianças como salada né
obrigadas pela mãe pode quer se formar
em filosofia enquanto está todo mundo se
formando em coisas mais seguras né como
direito administração ódio
tudo podia então no meu segundo livro a
dedicatória foi pra minha mãe eu gostei
assim para a minha mãe que sempre me
disse 'vai porque ela sempre me disse
'vai isso se estendeu por uma idade
adulta eu acabei me tornando o colunista
de sexo entre outras coisas de uma
revista masculina da vip e nas colunas
são sempre bem polêmicas e minha mãe
adorava essa polêmica
um dia a gente estava até tava eu e
amigos num restaurante em uma mesa e ela
chegou elogiando muito uma última coluna
minha e ela usava termos muito fofos
para hoje a coluna nem falava que é
muito sensível e um tecido muito sincera
e que maneira interessante com abordei
aquele tema e quem ouvia parecia que a
coluna era sobre amor é algo do tipo
então quando perguntaram o que ela disse
sexo anal e ela que 70 anos mesmo ou
seja realmente eu não tive tabu
essa coluna da vip tem sempre ao lado do
texto uma foto minha e mail sensual
isso eu sempre levei muito com um
espírito mais sabe o tipo assim eu vou
quebrar essa dicotomia machista de que a
mulher não pode usar essa sensualidade e
também inteligente mas é curioso porque
mesmo com toda essa liberdade todo esse
poder feminino exaltado e essa
naturalidade com o poder feminino
quando vinham me entrevistar sobre um
livro meu ou quando me perguntavam
alguma palestra porque eu tinha começado
a escrever sobre sexo
eu me via justificando intelectualmente
eu falava não foi na faculdade de
filosofia porque eu me interessava muito
pelos filósofos que tratavam do corpo
o meu tcc em filosofia inclusive foi a
sexualidade como afirmação
ida eu falava que durava há e literatura
erótica que eu realmente adoro mas se
estava neném henry miller batatais
estava nomes eu eu precisava me
justificar intelectualmente então eu
percebi que eu tenho que me justificar
intelectualmente era completamente
contrário a todo esse poder eu pregava
porque eu tentava justificar dessa forma
porque achava que ia ser mais sério
porque eu achava que eu ia ser mais
respeitada porque infelizmente o prazer
feminino ainda é tabu
isso eu vejo se aplica para todas as
mulheres inclusive dizem que a gente nem
gosta muito né de sexo já que a mulher
não é tão visual ela não gosta de pornô
que a libido dela não é tão explosiva
quando o homem que é absurdo mas enfim a
idéia é que tentam nos vender nem muito
sexual a gente pode ser e eu acho que a
gente vive uma feudo liberdade
a gente acha muito livre né porque a
gente pode dar no primeiro encontro a
gente se acha muito livre porque a gente
pode transar com quem a gente quiser nós
achamos muito livre porque podemos expor
nossos corpos nas redes sociais
mas entre quatro paredes essas mesmas
mulheres estão livres tão afim de
orgasmos
essas mesmas mulheres livres estão
sentindo inadequadas porque não
conseguem gozar 15 minutos como manda a
cartilha do reeducando ante do pornô
essas mesmas mulheres estão
insatisfeitas com esse sexo falou
cêntrico que é tido como normal
foi então eu percebi que o empoderamento
precisa passar pela sexualidade
não adianta a gente ficar no mental a
gente precisa resolver essa nossa
sexualidade e adquirir essa liberdade de
verdade pra que haja empoderamento então
eu fico vendo assim as pessoas ficam em
manifestações tão livres lutando por
tudo mas no fim das contas
nela estão lutando por causas sociais
políticas mas o corpo delas
recebi ontem mesmo a mensagem de uma
leitora
ela estava me contando que ela só usava
com o sexo oral
ok tudo bem mas ela me disse isso como
se fosse um problema
ela disse que ela estava com um novo
namorado novo namorado estava cobrando
dela orgasmo com penetração ou seja tem
coisas muito rivers nessa situação eu
acho que mostra coisas muito rígidas da
nossa sociedade primeiro ela tava
subjugando prazer dela
o desejo do outro e o outro namorado
tava querendo que ela tivesse um tipo
específico de orgasmo que ele idealizou
como se houvesse uma maneira de ter
orgasmo
claro que eu disse pra ela pode usar
como ela quiser que claro que é normal e
que ela pedisse para ele sem medo
utilizada no sexo oral maravilhoso nela
porque ela merece
ou seja a gente precisa rever isso antes
de dizer bater no peito e dizer que a
gente é livre
então aconteceram dois também antes na
minha vida mudaram não quiseram
aprofundar um pouco essa visão de
empoderamento precisa passar pela
sexualidade
um deles foi a morte da minha mãe
essa mesma que me ensinou tudo que eu
sabia sobre o poder feminino
não sei se vocês já passaram por isso
vi a morte de alguém que vocês amo mas
vê um corpo morto que a um minuto atrás
tinha vida e coloca no vazio existencial
que faz questionar absolutamente tudo
porque você não sabe que aquilo ali
aquilo que estava ali naquele corpo e
agora não está mais deixando aquele
corpos baseado sem sentido nenhum
então pela primeira vez na minha vida eu
me vi baixando na cabeça admitindo que
não sabia nada e sentindo eu me
perguntava por oe agora net e agora essa
árvore que eu faço né
então eu baixei a cabeça e admite que
realmente nada que eu tinha aprendido na
minha vida
intelectualmente vale alguma coisa ali
eu quis essa transição pela primeira vez
da mente do corpo e foi um exercício de
humildade epistemológica muito muito
grande na mesma fase entrou tantra na
minha vida eu acabei me tornando o
terapeuta tântrica também informada pelo
centro metamorfose e otan para ele usa o
corpo como transcendência através de
meditações massagens ele conduzia
energia que geralmente energia sexual
geralmente a gente concentrar nesse
chacra o chakra básico para os outros ou
seja a gente usa essa energia vital pra
outras áreas da nossa vida e por exemplo
pegar uma mulher abusada sexualmente
é muito mais fácil tratar ela através do
tantra do que eu ficar mil horas
conversando com ela às vezes a gente
trabalha um trauma e nem sente nem
entende racionalmente que a gente
resolveu ele mas do corpo resolveu e
através do tanto ressignificando a
relação com o meu corpo eu percebi que é
justamente essa relação com o corpo que
nos foi negado ao longo da história pra
nós mulheres desde que lhe tira a mão
daí menina até dificuldade que a gente
tem de entender as mil possibilidades de
prazer que a gente tem a questão do
cheiro a gente acha que suja né a
questão de a gente não saber como é
nossa anatomia
qual foi a última vez que você olhou
para sua vagina
será que você já olhou mesmo na sua
vagina titular mesmo entendendo a minha
talvez você tenha se lá 40 anos e nunca
ter olhado pra sua vagina
simplesmente a vagina é o maior dos
tabus
eu não quero aqui ficar apontando
culpados eu quero propor soluções e eu
acho que o empoderamento de verdade
precisa passar por essa resignificação
da nossa relação com a nossa vagina
só assim ter uma boa relação com a nossa
vagina com nossos orgasmos é que a gente
vai conseguir uma vida criativa poderosa
plena tudo isso que a gente quer e acha
que vai conseguir em outras áreas
agora eu queria propor uma coisa pra
vocês eu queria que vocês pensarem no
melhor orgasmo que vocês já tiveram mas
deixa deixa de lado o lado racional
afasta o lado racional tenta lembrar com
riqueza de detalhes mas tenta pensar
além do momento em si dos espasmos do do
tesão do momento tentando pensar nas
horas seguintes
tento pensar nos dias seguintes no humor
de vocês como dou aquela sensação de
auto respeito de autoconfiança na
liberdade que vocês sentirão tentei
pensar em como de repente vocês
conseguiram ver relação de tudo contudo
pareceu meio hip pra vocês
essa coisa da relação do meu futuro eu
sei que vocês sabem do que eu estou
falando porque o orgasmo cura mas para
que haja essa transcendência e se o
orgasmo realmente transformadora e
orgasmo te dá voz que tinham puderá você
precisa receber unificar a relação com a
sua vagina
só assim só com essa reforma sexual que
passa por esse enquadramento que passa
por orgasmos verdadeiros pressa
resignificação só assim a gente vai
conseguir um pagamento que a gente cá eu
entrevistei uma vez há exatos pornô
sasha grey foi um ícone de poder no meio
extremamente machista pornô ela me disse
uma coisa que eu nunca vou esquecer
quando perguntei sobre a relação dela
com sexo ela me disse é love my pulse e
é isso eu acho que a gente pode
significar essa relação de mil formas
mas antes de qualquer coisa a gente
precisa reaprender a amar a nossa vagina
obrigada
[Aplausos]